this feels quite a bit staged you know I
will make sure you don't run into the
wall
500 is it cold outside I've never seen
you with a target for elbrun how's the
weather out there do you know your
schedule right now if I ask you what
you're doing thank you now we just go
one by one half the staff wait I have a
semblance but I couldn't direct you
where we going now I know we're gonna go
some door come free yeah I know we're
gonna do that I know I'm gonna announce
a program on Syria I don't know okay
here in Georgia
we'll see you thank you Jesse what a
football game last night
Steelers they lost I did this is this
the LOB right here
it's my pleasure found her this morning
to join senator John Sununu and Peter
Thompson and that so many other public
officials and private citizens around
the state in extending my endorsements
to Governor John Kasich of Ohio and his
campaign for the office of president
this is a big deal to have to have
Gordon Humphrey and of course Peter
Thompson like the call one the president
of states and the leadership in the
Congress of the United States to create
sanctuaries safe havens in Syria perhaps
along the Jordanian border perhaps along
the border with Turkey where we would
create no-fly zones that they're seeing
well you know what slate was interesting
to me is there kind of bragging about
being in my library no I have a library
in Westerville at the Westerville
library it's really cool they kind of
set up my old congressional office and
now they have material from me being
governor and all that and I love when
people visit that library I just never
expected Bush people to be directed to
that library but they're saying they're
having a lovely time I would think that
they're in there because they're getting
nervous but when you're you know when
you're trailing in places like New
Hampshire where John Sununu is build a
great team you know you're not doing so
hot in other places of course they're
gonna go looking around it and who might
be the mature adult who knows how to
reform and fix things and and be a
leader rather than an administrator who
would be against the no-fly zone what's
argument against oh it'd be it would be
provocative
provocative well wouldn't want to make
the Russians mad because they might fly
their plane in there
have you met Putin no I never have what
do you think of him personality wise
from afar I think he's I think he's a
little bully is what I think he is and I
think he will push you as far as he
can't until you say no well you're out
here obviously got a couple endorsements
today that's good but how do you sort of
score a day on the trail like what makes
it a good day you know for me there's
two ways in which I determine we have a
good day
and we've had a lot of good days what I
see with my eyes and what I feel with my
gut what have you already eaten today
hit some fruit what else
eggs eggs
Bruton eggs how many calories do you
think you leave today I don't know I
don't think about it when will you eat
next thinking about I'm not I'm not
hungry right
Oh a town hall oh good you go and then
well she's young she's got yours screwed
up already
oh then your presser in there I mean
they're in there you know bragging that
they're in there investigating me come
on
so seriously you're can't they look at
other candidates records I don't think
we've done I've done that I know of at
this point I don't think so we're
certainly not going into their libraries
or something and archives and I guess
you know at some point I guess we'll
probably do that not but you know it's
kind of you know it's a little early for
that maybe not when you do that but did
you before you did that today did you
check with to visit your team or that is
all case existent no I didn't check with
anybody what are the three artists jobs
you ever had you know what you know is
it's always the hardest thing for me I
guess in any job is when
you know I think I'm sort of more
natural to to be
I mean I think I was sort of born and
raised or whatever is sort of be a
leader and whenever I'm in a position of
where I can't lead it's really hard for
me you know what's interesting about
this process is it's almost like
training to run you know a race the more
you do it the more you get accustomed to
it